- Hi there.
I'm Seth Juarez, and I'm chatting
with Microsoft
Research's Katja Hofmann
and Evelyne Viegas about Project Malmo,
an AI testing environment
based upon Minecraft.
Welcome!
- Hi, Seth.
- How's everybody doing today?
- Fantastic.
Great day.
- So, I heard about this topic recently,
and it absolutely was
really impressive, and here's why.
Like I was talking before,
I talked to Yoshua Bengio about deep learning,
and one of the things he said is that
one of the state-of-the-art things
that he wants to do
is he wants to use
deep learning for exploratory AI.
So, why don't you talk about Project Malmo
and why this is a perfect piece of software for that.
Why don't we start with you?
- Absolutely.
We really see Minecraft as one of those stepping stones
that are going to allow us
to push the state of the art in AI
and eventually work towards more
complex real-world applications.
Two of the things that I'm really excited
about that we can do in Malmo,
which is based on Minecraft,
is that first we can invest
in this kind of life-long learnings.
So, coming up with approaches
that bootstrap from smaller,
kind of simpler tasks
that learn common-sense knowledge
and then build that up to eventually
solve harder and harder tasks.
The other part that I'm really excited
about is this concept of collaborative AI,
so what happens when you put more
than one agent into an environment.
For example, how can AI agents learn to collaborate,
and what happens when you put a human in there?
Can they learn to figure out
what the human is trying to achieve
and how they can help them
achieve their goal?
- Well, Project Malmo.
Tell us about it from your perspective.
- Sure, so this is a very exciting project,
and I actually want to bring right now
the collaborative aspect
that Katja was talking about.
In fact, when we started the project,
when Katja started with the researchers
working on this project,
we started interacting with
the external community upfront,
just to understand first what was the need,
what were the requirements.
And we did a few what we call some technology days,
just to figure out, to listen to the community.
And pretty soon, we figured out
that actually it would be fantastic
if we could work more closely
with the community,
which ended up bringing Malmo, this platform,
to the open source.
And since then, actually, we've had
thousands of people who've been using it.
- That's amazing, so you started upfront by thinking,
"We're just going to put this out."
What have people been doing?
Because you mentioned thousands.
What have people been doing with this technology?
- Absolutely.
So, we were planning this as a tool
for the research community from the start
and really thinking about how such a platform
could advance the state of the art in AI.
One thing we hadn't really anticipated
was the level of enthusiasm
we got from outside
the research community.
We get high school students
who learn to program on the Malmo platform,
and that's really exciting for them,
because you can actually see what an algorithm does
when you use it to steer an agent.
We get a lot of interest
from university professors, who use it in their courses
to teach students
about concepts in AI
and programming and reinforcement learning.
So, there's a huge diversity of users.
A lot of times, we only see
the visitor numbers on GitHub.
We see that there's a lot of people,
but there's a lot bubbling under the surface
that we're not even aware of.
So, if you have some cool users for Malmo
that you would like to tell us about,
definitely get in touch.
We're really eager to hear about that.
- What's the most surprising thing
you've seen people use Project Malmo for?
- Gosh, I'll tell you first who is
the most surprising person I've seen.
- Let's do that, yeah.
- There was a sixth grader once who actually
came to my office and was completely inspired.
He was doing a visit as part of some
students' gathering at Microsoft,
and he had heard about Malmo.
Actually, he had really heard about Minecraft, right?
[ Laughter ] - Of course.
Who hasn't?
- He was really into Minecraft.
But then, he heard about Malmo and was like, wow.
So, he started to interact actually
with the researchers and say, you know,
"Wow, now I can actually
have some AI agents.
I can play with it, I can learn about it."
And so that was to me probably
the most surprising person
trying to use Malmo,
also showing that the bar
of entry can be as low
or as high as we want it to be.
- And that's amazing.
Were they actually coding these things
to go around and mine stuff and build stuff,
or what was this
sixth grader actually doing?
Just interest, or what were they doing?
- I think they were trying to do
a little bit of both, right?
The first thing, they were really trying to learn
about like, what's this whole agents?
How can I start coding?
But actually, the person started coding, actually.
So, yes, it was really
an environment to experiment,
to have fun with the characters
he was very familiar with.
- Let's talk about a test bed like Project Malmo.
Why is it an important thing?
- Well, in real-world applications --
which, in the long run,
we really want to enable
real-world applications.
We're not doing this for the sake
of learning to play Minecraft.
I mean, if that's what we need, we have
people who are pretty good at this.
But what we really want is to isolate certain aspects
of this whole huge problem of AI
and start to make progress
in those specific dimensions.
And in a simulated environment like this,
we can specifically construct the tasks
that allow us to really push on
those dimensions.
For example, if someone wants to do
research on multimodal approaches
that integrate language
and visual aspects
of an environment,
this is something you can
set up very easily in Malmo.
And it allows you to really focus
on the learning approach itself
instead of having to do all this data collection
setting up a task in the real world,
which can be much slower.
Eventually, we see this research
to feed into the real-world applications,
but first we can push,
really understand what's going on.
- Why do you think it's such an important test bed?
- Well, I think it's really important
because I'm going to go back to the community.
Actually, I want to talk about collaborative
AI challenge that we've done recently.
- Oh, interesting.
- This is one way,
as Katja was mentioning earlier,
really the goal of the platform --
not just doing the platform
for the sake of doing it --
is really to help advance
the state of the art,
to get people engaged.
Also, to use it for people maybe
to just learn, like PhD students,
but also some enthusiasts
actually are interested in learning
a bit about all these approaches.
So, the team put together an AI challenge.
I think Katja will be describing it
a bit later on in more detail, but I want to emphasize
that the interesting part
about that challenge
is that it's really collaborative.
This is all really about collaborative AI,
and I think that's something we're trying to do
which is different
from what is out there.
And Project Malmo actually is ideal for that,
which is bringing people together
to try to do some specific task,
like about creating something.
Or in the context of the challenge
that we had, this was actually a task
about trying to catch a pig together.
[ Laughter ]
- I feel like we've talked about this a lot.
Can you show us a little demo on how this works?
What do you got?
- Absolutely.
I think you can actually see this on the screen there.
- Totally can.
- What I have here is the task
that we set out
as the collaborative AI challenge.
We are going to be a human agent
interacting with another agent,
and the task of the students
was to actually create an agent
that would take the role
that we're playing here.
- OK.
- So, you can see here,
we're getting ready to catch the pig.
There are two agents in this small enclosure here,
and we are controlling the red agent here,
and there's another one here
in the corner.
To catch the pig, we actually have to corner it,
so we have to collaborate.
But that will only work if the other agent
is actually able to collaborate with us.
- Sure.
- So, let's see if they're a good collaborator.
- So, you're the red one,
and the blue one is the actual AI one.
- Exactly.
You can see how I'm controlling this one over here,
and you can already see that the other agent
is moving towards the pig,
so that's a pretty good indication
that they're actually trying
to collaborate with us.
And this inference, this kind of understanding
what the other agent's intentions are
and how our plan,
our behavior, can fit in to coordinate with them,
that is really the core
of this challenge.
If the other agent were to move around randomly
or were trying to trick us,
then we should draw
a different conclusion.
We shouldn't try to collaborate with them.
- So, this is interesting.
Because I'm looking at this, and I can think --
because I'm kind of a programmer, too.
Is this- like, are people writing
deterministic algorithms for them?
Are they probabilistic?
Are they going full AI machine learning?
What are they doing for this, Katja?
- Fantastic question.
So, we actually had 83 teams
from around the world participating
in this first version
of the challenge,
and what we saw in the winning teams
was that there was a huge variety
in terms of the approaches
that people tried.
Some people really went down
the deep reinforcement learning route
and had some great insights
into how to learn efficiently
in this kind of more complex
modeling environment.
Others went the classic AI route.
Some spent a lot of time
really manually modeling this environment.
Some went via belief modeling
and probabilistic inference.
And at the moment, what we saw was that
a lot of those approaches
were kind of on par
with each other.
So, what I'm looking forward
to is seeing how those different communities,
people with those
different backgrounds,
can learn from each other,
maybe integrate different ideas,
and use that to come up
with more new,
innovative approaches to solving
those kinds of collaborative tasks.
- What surprised you
about this challenge?
Because I'm sure you put this out there,
and you're like, "I wonder what's going to happen,"
and then you got
a lot of a response.
What was your reaction to this?
- Well, it was fantastic to see
so many people collaborate.
As Katja was mentioning, so the task itself
seemed kind of simple,
but actually what was
really interesting
when we had the winners
come and talk about
their different approaches...
First of all, actually, some of them
just collaborated just to present their approach,
so that speaks to the point
of their approaches;
some of them were
not that different.
And the other aspect also very interesting,
I thought, was- Actually, even for us,
trying to learn how people
are collaborating,
and some of them had some approach
they were trying to kind of trick
the pig, so to speak.
[ Laughter ]
- That's funny.
- It's also learning a lot
about how agents, whether humans or AI agents,
are also trying to collaborate
to achieve a specific task
and solve a problem, so that was really interesting.
Beyond the challenge, I think it's also
seeing what motivates people,
what are the incentives,
so it's learning a lot about that too
as we design our challenges.
- As I'm looking at this, if I was going
to perform part of this challenge,
I would have to program the agent
to help me corner the pig, effectively.
- Exactly.
- So, I'm a programmer.
How do I write this?
Because if I remember right,
it's written in Java, or at least Minecraft is.
But can you use any kind of language?
How do I get started?
What do I do to make this work?
- Fantastic question.
We from the start defined Project
Malmo to be as open as possible,
so we didn't want
to exclude any audiences.
We put a lot of effort into making
this platform actually cross-platform,
so it runs on Linux, Windows, Mac OS,
and people can use their
favorite programming language
to start and code agents.
Project Malmo essentially
provides an API that hooks into the Minecraft game,
so it uses the modeling framework
to get information
about the state of the world
and present commands to Minecraft.
But our platform takes away all the complexity
of actually interacting with the Minecraft game,
so that researchers can just focus
on starting to write code
of what the agent
should observe,
how it should interpret
those observations,
and how it should consequently
try to act in the world.
The languages we support include C,
C++, Java, Python, Lua, so there's a lot for everyone.
- I also saw there's a C#
one.
That's my favorite one.
- [ Laughing ] Absolutely.
- When I'm writing this stuff, am I...
I'm trying to understand what this looks like,
because it feels like there's some kind of wrapper
that I'm sending information to,
and then I'm querying
for information.
Is that the whole of it?
What do you say?
- Yes, absolutely.
- Yeah, so you really can think
about this as this interactive loop
between the agent on one side
and the world,
the Minecraft environment, on the other.
For the person writing the agent,
that looks quite simply
as you're pulling a state
from the environment,
and then you send an action back.
So, you can really start to think
about this kind of interactive loop
that is often used,
for example,
in reinforcement learning
but that also matches a lot
of different interactive scenarios
where agents have to generally learn
to interact with the world.
- One of the things I notice is that
this challenge was very constrained.
Is there a way that I can code- Let's just say,
for example, there's some heuristics
about how I think I can stay alive
at night in Minecraft.
And I have kids, so that's why
I know a lot about Minecraft, FYI.
So, let's just say there's certain assumptions
I have about staying alive in Minecraft.
Is there a way to code it into that,
so that it can unconstrained,
to see how it would
actually do something?
- Yeah, so the Malmo platform
is really open-ended in the sense
that it supports
infinitely many different tasks.
I'm just showing here a small snippet from the XML
that is actually used to define
the collaborative task
that we saw earlier.
And you can define kind of the world
that the agent enters.
You can start from
any saved Minecraft game.
You can add additional elements.
You can draw entities into this world.
So, you can really set it up in whatever way you like,
and then you can provide information
about what kinds of agents
should be put in that environment.
You can give them a certain reward function,
you can give them observation or command handlers,
and in this way, there's no limit
to what kinds of tasks
you can implement there.
So, if you think you can come up with an agent
that will survive the first 20 days, absolutely.
That's a task you can try on there.
- Also, they can talk, right?
- They can communicate with each other, exactly, yeah.
- So, by communicate with each other,
it's like you can send-
Because I know you can chat on Minecraft,
and they can receive
that text and do stuff with that.
- Mm-hmm, exactly.
Exactly, yeah, so you can start
to have collaborative tasks
where agents have to learn
to talk to each other when necessary.
- I feel like I just want to start
coding something right now.
So, this XML file describes the starting point.
You mentioned that it has- like,
if you could scroll down to
where it actually describes the agents,
because that's like-
our audience can see.
There's an agent, and so that agent...
How does it kn- That's what it has,
what it starts with.
How do you tell it,
like - because I imagine...
Look, I used to write games a long time ago,
and there was this loop that I would be able to know
"here's the thing here's what everything
is around it,; do this."
How do I tell the start file
to look at this function,
and then what do I get out of that function?
You see what I'm asking?
- Right, right.
For that, maybe let's look back at the Malmo
GitHub repository right here.
- Let's do it.
- This comes with a lot of example code,
so let's look here.
This is actually a great place to start
if you want to figure out what's out there.
So, you can see there's some C#
examples, C++, et cetera.
Many of them are in Python.
Let me just dive in there.
- Yeah, it's just super simple
to mock up those things, yeah.
- Exactly.
We ship with a tutorial, so that is a great
starting point to just get a feel
for what kind of functionality is supported,
and then we can look at maybe
the first tutorial,
which just demonstrates
how to set up a simple agent
and kind of set up
this interactive loop.
So, there's a little bit of boilerplate code,
and just sending the mission XML
that you just defined
to the Minecraft client.
We'll wait until that is all started up,
and then once the mission has begun,
we can simply access the state
of the world by interacting
with what's called the agent host.
So, it's a matter of getting the world state,
interpreting the world state in whatever way we want,
and then starting to send
commands to the environment.
This one is not the slowest task, so I would say
if people want to know more and try it out,
check out the tutorial
and get started on
coding up your first agent.
- This is really impressive, because like I say,
because AI is such a huge topic.
And people, when they think AI,
they think machine learning,
but you can use Dijkstra's algorithm
to do stuff in AI.
There's tons of applications for this.
What's the future for Project Malmo?
What are you most excited about
that people may or may not do?
- First of all, you just mentioned earlier,
we did this first challenge
that was just- you know,
we just put it out there,
tried to figure out
what people can come up with.
And I think the future where one of them
is already learning from what was put out there,
and we're already thinking
and actually send an invitation
to everybody here
listening to this livestream.
If you have some ideas about what would be
another collaborative AI challenge,
please just go to GitHub
, go to the forum,
and bring your ideas,
because we're here to learn and then share
with the broader community the platform.
We will continue to work on the platform,
and it will evolve as people start participating.
- Awesome.
Well, this has been super fun.
I am going to go home and try this today.
Can I just use this
with any version of Minecraft?
Do I have to have one that can be modded?
How do I download this for now?
- Actually, everything is included
in the installers.
If you just go to the GitHub repository,
follow the installation instruction,
you should be up and running in about half an hour.
- Awesome.
Thank you, Katja and Evelyne for a peek
into a really creative way to try out AI research.
Now, I want to go home and play Minecraft.
You got me inspired, seriously.
I'm really excited.
My kids are going to love this.
I'm going to teach them how to program with this.